my new series loki is coming soon to
disney plus and to help get you ready
i'm going to catch you up in just 30
seconds
my dad odin says my brother thor could
be king i'm jealous plus he's not my
real dad so i get my real dad to kill
odin but then i save him thor's man
anyway i'll be fine cut to earth i steal
the tesseract from shield help with
atari invade earth and the avengers stop
them and i go to jail until thor needs
me to help defeat the dark elves next
thing you know i'm king but everyone
thinks i'm odin our sister hella shows
up q another four loki team up we beat
her then thanos shows up we don't need
him and i die thanos kills half the
universe he managed to go back in time
to stop him giving an earlier version of
me a chance to grab the test right off
hang on
okay that's better
house gets defeated and the next thing
you know i've got a job offer from some
group that calls itself the tva
and that's it
find out what happens next by streaming
loki exclusively on disney plus
[Music]
you